cárter ha observado algunas relaciones
cuantitativas relacionadas con el éxito
de su equipo de fútbol y las ha modelado
con las siguientes funciones y observa
esto está muy interesante tenemos aquí
una función que está siendo denotada con
la letra mayúscula n cuya entrada es el
porcentaje de victorias denotado con la
letra w y su salida es el número
promedio de aficionados por juego así es
que cárter está haciendo una especie de
modelo que nos dice que el número
promedio de aficionados por juego
depende del porcentaje de victorias del
equipo y bueno yo supongo que en este
modelo entre mayor es el porcentaje de
victorias mayor es el número promedio de
aficionados ahora por otro lado también
tenemos la función w cuya entrada es el
tiempo promedio de práctica diaria
y cuya salida es el porcentaje de
victorias y bueno esto también tiene
sentido y seguramente aquí entre mayor
es el tiempo de práctica diaria mayor es
el porcentaje de victorias y luego
también tenemos esta función pe cuyas
entradas son el número de días lluviosos
en la temporada y cuyas salidas es el
tiempo promedio de práctica diaria y
bueno aquí entre mayor sea el número de
días lluviosos menor va a ser el tiempo
promedio de práctica diaria y aquí
también podemos ver muy fácilmente como
el tiempo promedio de práctica está en
función del número de días lluviosos y
luego por aquí nos preguntan cuál de las
siguientes opciones representa la
expresión n de w de x pero bueno antes
de ponernos a ver todas estas opciones
primero pensemos en qué es lo que esto
significa hay otra forma de denotar esto
porque por aquí tomamos este
tenemos aquí a la equis y vamos a usar
esa equis como la entrada de la función
w porque le vamos a dar esta entrada a
la función
wv y esto lo que nos va a dar es w de x
aunque esta es la salida y luego vamos a
usar esta entrada y se le vamos a dar a
la función n ok se la damos a la función
n y lo que nos da la salida es n v w x
así es que ahora pensemos en qué es lo
que hace esta función w bueno pues la
función w ve al porcentaje de victorias
como función del tiempo promedio de
práctica así es que estamos usando como
entrada el tiempo de práctica tiempo de
práctica
así es que tomamos el tiempo de práctica
y se lo damos como entrada a la función
w la cual con esa información de cierta
forma predice el porcentaje de victorias
porcentaje de victorias y luego tomamos
ese porcentaje de victorias y se lo
damos como entrada a la función n y la
función n nos va a dar el número
promedio de aficionados por juego de
acuerdo al porcentaje de victorias así
es que este es el número de aficionados
y entonces cuando tomamos la función
compuesta estamos haciendo una función
que tiene como entrada el tiempo de
práctica y que nos da el número de
aficionados por juego dependiendo del
tiempo de práctica que tengamos así es
que esto es bastante interesante y por
aquí en estas opciones lo que tenemos
que hacer es buscar una opción en la que
el número de aficionados depende del
tiempo de práctica al cual estamos
denotando por una equis la primera
opción nos dice que esto
representa el porcentaje de victorias
del equipo como función del tiempo
promedio de práctica ahora el porcentaje
de victorias del equipo eso es
simplemente w x y aquí tenemos una
expresión un poco más complicada
entonces podemos directamente tachar
esta opción ahora en la siguiente opción
tenemos el número promedio de
aficionados por juego lo cual está
bastante interesante porque esa sí es la
salida final de nuestra expresión y el
número promedio de aficionados por juego
si es la salida de la función n de la
función n ahora tenemos el número
promedio de aficionados a un juego muy
bien como función del número de días
lluviosos en la temporada pero no
nosotros no lo estamos haciendo así
nosotros lo estamos haciendo como
función del tiempo de práctica
definitivamente si podríamos construir
esto esta opción sería algo así como
como función de w como función pero aquí
en lugar de simplemente una equis
tendríamos que poner una p de r p de r y
esta sí es la expresión que representa a
esta opción porque aquí lo que hacemos
es utilizar como entrada el número de
días lluviosos y de esa forma calculamos
el tiempo de práctica promedio y usamos
eso como la entrada para calcular el
porcentaje de victorias y entonces
utilizamos esto como entrada para
encontrar el número promedio de
aficionados por juego pero eso no es lo
que estamos haciendo por aquí nosotros
estamos empezando con el tiempo de
práctica promedio para obtener el número
promedio de aficionados por juego
así es que también tenemos que tachar
esta opción y bueno sí en contraste un
poquito confuso todo esto que hicimos
por aquí te recomiendo que hagas un
diagrama como el de acá lo que yo bueno
que veas por ejemplo aquí estamos
empezando con r
qué es el número de días lluviosos en la
temporada y estamos usando esa entrada
para calcular pdr que es el tiempo
promedio de práctica diaria y luego
usamos ese resultado como entrada de la
función w ok porque esto es el tiempo
promedio de práctica diaria se lo damos
como entrada a la función w y obtenemos
el porcentaje de victorias y luego
usamos eso como una entrada en la
función n para obtener el número
promedio de aficionados por juego pero
eso es lo que tenemos por aquí todo esto
no es lo que tenemos en esta expresión
nw vdx pero bueno luego tenemos otra
opción que dice el número promedio de
aficionados por juego como función del
tiempo promedio de práctica diaria y si
eso sí es lo que tenemos por aquí creo y
empezamos con el tiempo de práctica
diaria x y se la damos como entrada a la
función w y nos da el porcentaje de
victorias
el porcentaje de victorias el cual lo
utilizamos como entrada para dárselo a
la función n que se lo damos como
entrada a la función n y nos da el
número promedio de aficionados por juego
así es que si tenemos el número promedio
de aficionados por juego como función
del tiempo promedio de práctica diaria
así es que si definitivamente estoy
segura de que esta es la opción correcta
bueno y ahora vamos a hacer otro
ejercicio denis estudio el parque
cercano a su casa y ahí identificó
varias relaciones cuantitativas y las
modelo con las siguientes funciones si
es que tenemos aquí a la función b que
tiene como entrada la altura de un árbol
equis y tiene como salida el número de
pájaros anidados en ese árbol luego
tenemos a la función h que tiene como
entrada la temperatura promedio en un
lugar específico y tiene como salida la
altura del árbol en ese lugar y
finalmente la función t que tiene como
entrada
de un lugar específico y tiene como
salida la temperatura promedio en ese
lugar y ahora nos preguntan cuál de las
siguientes expresiones representa la
altura de un árbol como función de la
altitud así es que lo que queremos como
salida es la altura de un árbol la
altura de un árbol como función de la
altitud así es que la entrada tiene que
ser la altitud bueno vamos a pensar en
esto si tomamos la altitud en un lugar
específico la altitud r y se la damos
como entrada a la función de lo que
obtendríamos sería t de r que representa
la temperatura promedio en ese lugar
pero ahora si tomamos esto como una
entrada y se la damos a la función h lo
que vamos a obtener es la altura de un
árbol en ese lugar no creo y vamos a
obtener h
de t
r así es que esto de aquí la salida es
la altura de un árbol así es que ya lo
tenemos aquí h dt de r no creo porque
empezamos con la altitud del lugar se lo
damos como entrada a la función t y
obtenemos la temperatura promedio y eso
se lo damos como entrada a la función h
y obtenemos la altura de un árbol en ese
lugar
así es que hdt de r ht de r esta opción
es una expresión que representa la
altura de un árbol como función de la
altitud